there's a funny and scary article from
Eric Levitz in New York Magazine and
he's pointing out something that we've
been reporting on piecemeal for several
months which is that Donald Trump seems
to become enraged when there is accurate
reporting about the impact of the
legislation he wants passed so forget
about low information voters who are
falling for this stuff we have maybe our
lowest ever information president and
the main point is Donald Trump doesn't
know what his policies are going to do
or what his proposals are going to do he
signs off on stuff maybe because someone
five minutes prior told him it was going
to be a good idea later he starts seeing
reporting about what the impact of his
policies would be and he ends up furious
usually with someone I guess whoever
suggested to him these ideas in the
first place so I'll give you some
examples right the Obamacare repeal
promise that he and many other
Republicans made during the campaign
that turned into the Republicans have
proposed a mean bill well yeah and
Donald Trump ended up furious with the
accurate coverage of what would happen
to people's health care if Trump care I
believe at the time 1.0 was enacted and
Obamacare repealed Trump campaigned on
I'm going to have a tax plan that's
going to be really really great for the
middle class he publishes the tax plan
and then the analyses accurately say
hold on a second this is a major
giveaway for the richest of all
Americans this is really going to do
nothing for the middle class it'll be
great for people with gigantic estates
accurate coverage Trump furious about
how the coverage is going because he's
just learning what the impact of his
policy is going to be another example
from the tax proposal Trump was fully on
board with this idea of repealing the
deductibility of state and local taxes
at the federal level everybody who has
some economic sense flips out and tells
Trump you know that that's terrible for
the middle class and now Trump is
furious and he has come out against the
elimination of that tax deductibility
for the state and local tax
and an important discussion that we have
to have when we talk about this is it's
very easy and I know I've talked about
is Trump suffering from the early stages
of dementia does Trump have Alzheimer's
this Trump have limited cognition or
limited ability to read it becomes sort
of an easy out in a way because it
excuses Donald Trump being genuinely
clueless and in over his head and it
excuses those who voted for Donald Trump
right because if we just write off the
the the total lack of connection to the
real world impact of Donald Trump's
policies if we say it's not because he's
a genuinely selfish and bad guy it's not
because he's in way over his head if we
say it's it's dementia or Alzheimer's
we're excusing those who voted for
Donald Trump and we shouldn't be doing
that they don't deserve to be excused
for having put this guy in the Oval
Office and I don't know the reality of
the possible diagnosis of Donald Trump
whether it is limited literacy or
Alzheimer's or dementia or whatever the
case may be but the problem here is
under the under the understanding that
Donald Trump is not currently senile he
is clueless on policy and appears to
genuinely not be a good person there's a
conversation I saw from an interview
recently that Donald Trump did with
Forbes is Randal Lane and it's an
example of this total lack of
understanding that doesn't seem to be
dementia or Alzheimer's and the
conversation that they had is one where
Randal Lane said about Donald Trump's
tax plan so it's a massive tax cut but
then that runs against your pledge to
not increase the deficit because you
can't you know and Trump says no because
no because a tax cut will spur growth
and Lane says yes that is true and there
is dynamic scoring and Trump adds the
growth the growth will be so much that
it'll be and lane interrupts and says
yeah but history has shown that you
can't just cut it does spur growth but
it won't pay for itself history has
shown that and Donald Trump says well
history has also shown the opposite I
mean you've had it both ways it has
shown both ways so Donald Trump then
tries to come up with a
example of when tax cuts have been
economically stimulative above and
beyond the decreased revenue and he says
well during Reagan he tremendous growth
and Lane accurately points out there was
growth but it ballooned the deficit I
want to think through an example here
because if you just put in two minutes
of time into thinking about this idea if
you cut taxes for the rich does it
really spur enough growth to make up for
the loss government revenue imagine an
economy that is ten thousand dollars
okay the total economy is ten thousand
dollars you want to cut the tax rate
let's say from 40 percent to 30 percent
okay so at a forty percent tax rate in
your ten thousand dollar economy that's
four thousand dollars in tax revenue if
you cut the tax rate to 30 percent
you now have three thousand dollars in
tax revenue so your play is you'll cut
the taxes you'll lose a thousand dollars
in tax revenue but the economy will grow
so much that you'll add more than a
thousand dollars in tax revenue in the
end in order for that to happen with a
30 percent tax rate to recover a
thousand dollars in tax revenue you need
your economy to grow $3,300
so the break-even is that the economic
multiplier on the cut money needs to be
3.33
if you give that thousand dollars in tax
cuts to the rich it is mostly going to
be saved because they don't need that
money and they are not going to put it
back into the economy in a way that will
have an economic multiplier 3.33 it just
won't work if you give a thousand
dollars to the rich you're not gonna
grow your economy by thirty three
hundred dollars and the problem is that
it's not just Trump who supports and
believes this stuff lots of voters
support and believe this stuff they've
all been bamboozled and no one knows any
better than the president so I think
that this is a very very good piece that
you should check out and we're linking
to it on YouTube because it points out
that Donald Trump genuinely is furious
when he finds out what his policies will
do because he doesn't understand what
they will do there is one area where I
disagree with this piece which is that
it seems to take the position that Trump
has good intentions and he's just kind
of an easily manipulated [ __ ] I've been
very clear it's clear to me that Trump
has a policy his personal philosophies
political philosophy is one of self
aggrandizement and self enrichment and
greed period so while I think the piece
is very well-written and it points out
Trump genuinely does become surprised
when he reads about the impact of his
policies I don't think the guy has great
intentions I think his only goal is self
enrichment self aggrandizement and
patting himself on the back and we've
been seeing that in terms of this
horrible hurricane recovery so check out
the article think about this example and
let me know where I'm going wrong if I
am I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is sponsored in part by
zip recruiter if you were hiring you
need to know where to post your job to
find the best candidates zip recruiter
makes it possible to post your job
listing to over a hundred job sites with
just a single click they will also use
their technology to match the right
applicants to your job better than
anybody else because unlike other job
sites zip recruiter does not depend on
candidates finding you it will find
candidates for your position and in fact
80% of employers who post a job on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through their website within the first
day the backend dashboard control panel
makes it so you don't have to juggle
emails or calls to your office you can
screen rate and manage candidates all in
one place this is the smartest way to
hire and you can find out today why zip
recruiter has been used by businesses of
all sizes for free because david pakman
show listeners and viewers can post jobs
unzip recruiter at no cost if you go to
zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman
that's zip recruiter comm slash PA que
ma n one more time try zip recruiter for
free at zippers com
/pa km am